[Applaudissements]
le besoin d'abord et d'appréciation est
bien plus grand dans le monde
vous présentez pas clairement mais
intérêt à venir pas goûté du poker
français
plus sérieusement je passe ma belle
chercher l'amour partout j'ai ri dans la
cwa redonne d'amélie ses volailles
piccioli dans une ancienne vie mais je
vite compris que je n'étais pas de salle
les vies d'autres qui cherchait cette
connexion profonde
pourquoi parce que candidats à l'amour y
a pas peur il ya de la vie je me
souviens d'une histoire d'une vie qui
vivait seul en ville
il avait 50 tentes et détesté son
travail et ce qui n'est pas très bien
également
elle verra ensuite elle est partie à son
employeur que même en actions
philanthropiques à l'autre bout du monde
sur les galettes indienne les
intouchables les opprimés les hors
castes les sociétés indiennes septième
saison de que dix jours mêlant est
rentré traumatisé tout choqué dans sept
voyages
comment me traiter des êtres de cette
manière là comme on pourrait vivre dans
une telle pauvreté
tous les chantiers tout le blesser et
quand on est rentrés elle disait ah tu
demandes
je ne retournerai plus honnête c'était
trop dur émotionnellement et après l
achat
y a rien changé dans sa vie elle est
retournée au même travail de près ce que
j'ai pu comprendre regardez elle
n'arrive pas vraiment grandi par cette
expérience
je me suis souvent demandé sur cette
envie si répondu de vouloir partir si
loin de chez soi pour aller la
découverte de soi
probablement parce que moi aussi je suis
parti de mon pays
il ya très longtemps pour venir en
france équité internet est à la
recherche de moi meme je sui vi compris
après l'avis qu'elle
finalement c'est aussi important de
petites erreurs de soi même et les
autres là où vous vous trouvez ici et
maintenant et qu'ils s'occupaient de
cette mort de soi jack of il a dit si
votre compassion ne veut surtout pas
vous même elle est incomplète la ré
connexions commence par soi mais ça
s'est ému digne sans arrêt m3m les
autres s'entendre avec les autres mecs
qui nous apprend comment faire
c'est pas des câbles c'est pas forcément
à la maison et portant les valeurs les
joies de vivre la connexion de la vie
qu'on a qui sort de ses rencontres ses
échanges avec les autres c'est vrai
qu'avec sim avec les autres est
formidable
en novembre 2003 je suis parti en
caressant les raisonnements mère malade
elle est en train de mourir du cancer du
poumon en phase terminale
qui ne fumait même pas et je suis à
l'aise en juin 2 pour le donner tout ce
que je pouvais en arrivant là bas je
déprime par une profonde tristesse une
révolte et donc il peut enfin ces
scénarii qui l'attaqué tel point que je
voudrais pas être à côté d'elle pour son
son dernier souffle
et puis deux semaines sur place et je
commence à concilier avec les émotions
qui commence à ouvrir le jeu qu'on a
évité de s'échapper
les brûlures à tout comprendre tout
contrôler il savait donner un profond
connexion d'amour avec ma mère tu me
suivait un deuil est toujours des
conversations connaît dans les derniers
dix jours avant qu'elle ait décidé on
était chez elle
les grandes soleil de californie du sud
new day d'oxygène
le flacon à morphine 60 est riche mais
l'odeur prononcé de la malaisie
c'était tellement pris par une sentiment
de culpabilité de marc schittly d'avoir
à les sinois à 11 ou d'immeubles telle
qu'elle est fourni pour venir en france
et on se voyait que très peu de retard
pris par cette terrible sentiment tué
devant les pardons de l'avoir quittée et
là elle m'a pris par la main me regarde
avec ses cieux du jus ce grand sourire à
marianne
elle m'a dit
suis tellement fier des trois de rides
j'admire ton indépendance je t'aime
tellement ne pense plus à tout ça j'ai
pas du tout plu au ray et par chance
j'ai pu être à côté galles pour son
dernier souffle
quand le coeur pour la traîne donc je
vais vers celle en tenue qui nous
connais tu as vraiment qui nous sommes
c'était un échange plutôt nationale
n'est pas son ego c'est une possibilité
de les sentir que nous sommes tous
partis ni de la plus grande communauté
du monde
ils sont tous membres du club de
l'humanité c'est pas cool on parle
beaucoup de générations différentes et
les générations humanité
nous y sommes tous
et on peut profiter de ça donne tous les
jours de nos vies c'est comme un terrain
de jeu le gîte de vie quotidienne que
nous avons autour de nous si nous
ouvrons vers les autres nous partageons
qui regarde un mot bien faisons on
pourrait s'échanger dans les yeux des
autres de majorque qui nous fait
comprendre que nous faisons plus partie
de ce monde en faisant un petit sondage
local ensemble se voulait bien
combien d'entre vous c'est en moins de 5
de vos voisins dans votre bâtiment ou
dans votre quartier
c'est pas mal bravo est ce que vous
cherchez à focaliser sur ce qui vous
unit candidat sur deux tandis que voit
ce que vous cherchez ce qui vous sépare
ça peut nous différencier qui provoque
des problèmes
on s'en fout
j'ai de très bonnes relations frais avec
toujours y avoir quelqu'un pour acquis
tournée pour le cycle qui ne manque ni
sport
mais s'ils ont passé et maintenant
parce qu'elle dit les gars d'el hamma du
jeu
tibétaine je suis but dit je suis le
candidat mais si je m'identifiais tu
sais identité réductrice selon eux c'est
un d autre
sacré de barrière entre eux et moi ça
donne ce dont nous avons besoin c'est de
prêter davantage attention ce qui nous
unit
ce qui nous rassemble
tu fais d expérience sensorielle et
émotionnelle autour du monde
et c'est toujours le moment incroyable
pour moi et les autres
vous lassez votre smartphone dans un
confort les journées d'un généreux vous
chez
j'ai vraiment aucun acte et il faut que
les uns cantine trail sur le rencontre
avec l'autre vous arrivez nous cherchons
pas focaliser sur des titres des
étiquettes ceux qui font les unes des
autres voitures dans lesquelles ils sont
arrivés le job qui font le sale qui
chant qu'ils ont ni leurs couleurs il
faut que les ondes sur les personnes qui
sont présentes parfois très connus
parfois pas connu du tout et nous
dansons ne chante on les à côté de pau
est confiée du mans jean de mets
succulents tout au long de la journée
parfois vous êtes spectateur d'autres
fois vous êtes participants active et
certaines verront peut-être une sortie 7
dans un simplement une fête et bien
d'autres une expérience
transformationnelle une meilleure
journée de dori
mais pourquoi
nous avons tous
m
dan est précieux les autres et aussi
d'être aimé et apprécié par les autres
tout simplement
blake
méthodes de reconnaissance c'est
l'expérience
alors est ce que vous voulez un petit
échantillon
cette expérience est découverte soit une
aventure avec l'autre
de courage et bienveillance aux unes aux
autres
ici et maintenant je pars temps alors
révèle que s'il vous plaît dans les rues
vers le personnage était de vous fermez
vos yeux mais d'y vendre eux-mêmes
droite sur votre coeur l'amour vous a
dit votre main gauche sur votre ventre
votre corps à respirer trois fois
profondément inspiré inspiré inspiré
l'histoire inspirée donnez donnez à vous
même l'empathie de bienveillance
l'appréciation que vous voulez recevoir
des autres sentiments que je fais partie
2 du tram de l'humanité ok maintenant
vous pouvez ouvrir les yeux et regarder
très gentiment de bienveillance
la personne qui est en face de vous
promener leur part le bras si vous
voulez rien
inspire
la sauvegarde est espéré dans les
dernières cette personne le sentiment la
complicité que vous faites partie des
sept grands crus et et vous êtes en
europe d'humanité et qu'ariel puisse
vous séparer et tu pouvoir assembler
resterait bien vous êtes t elle
vous êtes peut vous êtes tous les autres
qui sont dans nos salles
vous êtes les derniers indiens vous êtes
l'humanité vivante et vibrante
aspiré bien
exprimé à l'autre comme une récente et 7
bonheur de faire partie en sort de cette
magnifique arrêté
vous pouvez revenir maintenant si vous
voulez bien si vous pouvez celle aussi
des localités de bienveillance ils sont
maintenant ensemble
vous allez voir les prochaines fois
ça va être plus facile vous avez grandi
dg si émotionnellement
vous allez voir dans des situations de
vie
ping en plus anti moins intimes
vous pouvez commencer à tirer remonter
davantage autour de vous avec tout leur
encontre de votre vie
vous pouvez ainsi élargir notre capacité
d'offrir c'est une heure l'humanité sont
au mieux la vie viennent pressenti le
pouvoir de kim est un vrai avec les
autres c'est choisir de reconnecter avec
soi même et ses émotions et son joie de
vivre bien sûr et photos que les est
sûre ça qui les unit pas ce qu'ils
veulent c'est par ici
maintenant partout et en plus c'est
super sympa de train de chasser 13
élèves à les trouver l'amour partout je
pouvais lui dire car les gars a bien
résumé
m
c'est se reconnaître soi même
chez notre merci
[Applaudissements]